also ja gerade so jetzt war mal aus
jetzt immer drei wunderbar sehr schätzt
und er hört uns dass es schön neben mir
thomas ein gerade noch etwas
angeschnitten aber jetzt vor dem bild er
guckt auf eure kommentare
und ja ihr wisst ja 2321 zuschauer ich
habe mich ein wenig vorbereitet auf
dieses wunderbare thema so sehen
übrigens die skripte aus und so ich höre
auf dem schirm jetzt mich nochmal und
das müssen wir jetzt mal abschalten
das hört sich besser an so ich hoffe wie
ist der sound hört ihr das sind noch
alte kommentar sollte es funktionieren
so jetzt müsstet ihr dasein okay so
leute die wir haben hier unten da da da
da den livestream von spacex den
verfolgen wir jetzt hier in deutsch und
versorgt euch mit einer menge daten zu
diesem staat ja ich muss euch sagen es
ist für mich absolut gänsehaut pur man
darf nicht vergessen diese bilder von
dieser startrampe das ist nämlich die
apollo staat habe und lediglich apollo
10 ist nicht von dieser startrampe
gestartet und ich erinnere mich noch an
meine kindheit da stand dort eine saturn
5 auf der spitze die apollo kapsel und
ja sie war auf dem weg zum mond zum
ersten mal damals und das war wirklich
auch ein unglaubliches ereignis auf der
ganzen welt wir sehen jetzt übrigens
unten rechts da gehen wir mal ganz kurz
ins vollbild das sind die lande zonen
denn die booster die werden nachdem sie
abgetrennt worden sind von der
hauptstufe von der ersten stufe werden
zurück zur erde fliegen und direkt
nebeneinander auf diesen beiden flächen
landen und hier da sehen wir einen
spaceship ein schiff auf dem dann die
dritte der dritte teil dieser ersten
stufe landen wird und das ist im
atlantik und dieses schiff heißt of
course i love you
zitat aus einem roman da werde ich
gleich noch mal drauf kommen was das
genau ist ja diese kollegen die wir
übrigens da beide sehen das sind alte
veteranen myspace ex die den livestream
regelmäßig kommentieren und ja da da hat
man schon eine gewisse routine
entwickelt und ich glaube das ist auch
wirklich das absolut fantastische bei
spacex dass hier inzwischen das zu einem
normalfall geworden ist und wenn man
sich so das letzte jahr vor augen führt
als space ex wirklich ein paar rekorde
aufgestellt hat und zwar vor allem
dingen was die wiederverwendbarkeit von
raumschiffen dragon ist wieder verwendet
worden
die ersten stufen sind wieder verwendet
worden der falken nein dann ist das
jetzt hier ein absoluter höhepunkt denn
was hier passieren wird alle drei teile
der ersten stufe wenn alles klappt
werden auf der erde wieder landen und
können dann wiederverwendet werden
ja ich würde mal sagen wir fangen mit
dem intro an denn das gibt es immer am
anfang bei klicks so das war das intro
ich hoffe ihr habt was gehört ja und
worum es heute geht ist wirklich ein
absoluter meilenstein in der raumfahrt
denn elenas hat eigentlich nichts
anderes vor als den mars zu besiedeln
und wenn ihr mal auf die space seite
geguckt hat in den letzten stunden und
wollen euch das thumbnail angeguckt hat
dieses land stehen ja dann sah es wo
habe ich so habe ich es so happig so aus
und ja das ist nichts anderes als der
prozess des treffens des mars also das
ist der plan den allen masc letztendlich
verfolgt und die felgen ein
die falcon heavy sind zum einen
technisch nur zwischenstufen sie werden
in zukunft weiter ausgebaut
es gibt ja die bf die big fucking rocket
oder inzwischen auch etwas abgeschwächt
die big felken rocket eine rakete mit
der wirklich allen masc millionen
menschen am ende zum mars bringen will
ja aber dazu kommen wir später ist es
wird gleich werden wir sehen da gehen
wir jetzt noch mal hin
wir werden jetzt gleich sehen wie der
countdown abläuft wie das schiff startet
ihr seht unten im bild von space
exarchia sehen wir übrigens die ladung
und es ist wirklich auch eine geschichte
denn an am steuer dieses tesla roadsters
sitzt starman und starman ist nichts
anderes als eine figur eine kunstfigur
von david bowie ja und dementsprechend
das muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz hier
ins bild zeigen
dieses liegt space oddity von david
bowie das läuft in der anlage des tesla
roadsters persönlich sehr private tesla
roadster von allen masc der dort im
pilot der falken heavy ist da wird
dieses dieser saison laufen uns damals
ist eben ein alter ego von david bowie
der in diversen songs so weit ich weiß
sogar gesungen worden ist ja da gibt es
dann noch mehr was in diesem tesla ist
unter anderem wird es sein das buch per
anhalter durch die galaxis
unter anderem wird es sein ein handtuch
auch aus dem roman per anhalter durch
die galaxis auf dem dom panic steht also
ich kann nur empfehlen die bücher zu
lesen oder den spielfilm zulegen zu
sehen
das ist wirklich sehr lustig oder zeigt
diese probe ladung denn es ist ja nur
ein testflug diese probe ladung zeigt
den humor von allen masc weil er konnte
nichts anderes rein tun also alter den
tesla roadster in das payload gepackt
wohin der wagen reist das wissen wir
noch nicht denn einige stunden nach dem
start der rakete tätig wird und immer
wie bitte wir haben technische probleme
zu erlassen wir legen
das tut mir leid ja okay dass ein das
heißt für uns dass wir voraussichtlich
den lars schmidt unterbrechen müssen
okay weil
das leider so nicht funktioniert jetzt
geben aber hoch jetzt mal wieder das ist
nicht so das typische das ist mal hoch
mal runter her okay das heißt wir unser
rechner neu starten da reden wir auch
ohne längst wieder da und okay wir
starten das team gleich neu in wenigen
sekunden bleibt dran gleich gehts weiter
ja ich bin jedenfalls bislang okay sind
wieder da noch nicht es wird nicht
besser
wir könnten den router mal starten oder
stoppen
okay leute er wenn er das noch seht wir
starten konzentrierter und sind legal
einfach so
das hört sich auch nach tonstörungen
oder ruhe zumindest bei spacex an
da sind wir wieder ich weiß perfekt
funktioniert alles perfekt so dass es
doch erfreulich beim einstein bisheriger
achtung so liebe leute da sind wir
wieder
ich hoffe ihr habt uns gut wieder läuft
sehr gut
so liebe leute da sehen war es ist wird
langsam ruhig die aufregung steigt und
ich habe es gerade erzählt das alles ist
nur eine vorstufe die wir hier erleben
zu wirklich einer absolut neuen
legendären entwicklung in der raumfahrt
gehört den hatte man da muss ich ein
bisschen lauter machen den jubel im
hintergrund vielleicht ja gerade so wir
werden jetzt diverse anweisungen
ausgetauscht wir gehen mal in vollbild
man hört
wir sind eigentlich eine volle pulle wer
in istrien nichts wir gucken mal
es war nicht so schlimm es ist so so ihr
ist alles bereit für den start
der verkehr wird computer hat jetzt die
kontrolle übernommen über den start
das ist ja nach rakete die jetzt
insgesamt mit 27 melvin 1d triebwerken
ausgestattet ist sie wird gleich ein
schub aufbauen von 22,8 megatonnen mega
newtonmeter nuten ist ja die kraft und
ihr noch 30 sekunden
ihr könnt euch vorstellen ein newton ist
die kraft die man aufwenden muss um ein
kilogramm auf eine geschwindigkeit von
einem meter pro sekunde und das ist eine
menge zu kriegen so leute so jetzt gehen
wir mal die audioquelle europa dann
könnt ihr es über so achtung
es geht jetzt los und achtung
die falcon heavy startet wir sehen die
triebwerke zünden in moskau vorher
gesagt wenn das selbst so klappt das
wäre schon ein riesending und es ist
geklappt es abgeklappt ein absoluter
wahnsinn
die triebwerke zünden alle mit voller
kraft sie sind auch so konstruiert wenn
jetzt triebwerke tatsächlich ist nicht
schaffen würden ausfallen würden würde
trotzdem die mission weiter gehen und
könnte erfolgreich sein
also das ist wirklich eine absolute
sensation hier wird jetzt die geschichte
der menschheit neu geschrieben das ist
unfassbar was wir hier sehen und alles
funktioniert wie am schnürchen
es ist wahnsinn wir haben hier oben wir
sehen die geschwindigkeit im bild
beschleunigung ist wunderbar jetzt 1000
kilometer pro stunde
es ist wirklich absoluter wahnsinn hier
sehen wir übrigens auch die lande füße
der beiden booster und der ersten stufe
oben in der spitze der tesla roadster
es läuft alles absolut nach plan
wir haben jetzt die stelle der maximalen
beschleunigung erreicht hier sehen wir
auch und das ist auch besonders myspace
64 wir sehen wirklich jedes detail
überall sind kameras die europa europäer
bei der ariane-5 machen das nicht sie
fürchten viel zu sehr dass irgendwas
schief geht und hier klappt alles und
man darf nicht vergessen vor einigen
jahren haben wie viele viele leute
gesagt zum beispiel neil armstrong und
viele andere
das wird er nicht schaffen das ist
unmöglich und er schafft es besser als
alle anderen bisher hat jetzt wirklich
ihnen maskat die größte rakete der
aktuell muss man natürlich sagen der
welt gebaut und selbst wenn sie es
explodieren würde selbst wenn jetzt
irgendwas schief gehen würde
es ist ein absoluter meilenstein es ist
ein absoluter meilenstein aber es geht
nichts schief
es läuft alles wirklich wie am
schnürchen wir sind jetzt auch ganz kurz
vor dem booster engine car auf das ist
also der moment in dem die beiden
booster links und rechts von der ersten
stufe getrennt werden
das dauert jetzt noch ein paar sekunden
wir sehen oben rechts auch die höhe 54
kilometer über der erde geschwindigkeit
6700 kilometer pro stunde achtung und
jetzt sind wir kurz und da werden die
busse abgetrennt perfekt absolut wie im
bilderbuch
und die fallen jetzt zurück zur erde die
stürzen zurück zur erde
und zwar werden sie direkt neben dem
launchpad 39a dem apollo launchpad auf
festem boden landen der booster der die
erste stufe wird jetzt noch eine weile
brennen das ist aber auch nicht mehr
lang gleich wird sie auch abgetrennt vom
8 und jetzt
wird auch die erste stufe abgetrennt da
haben wir den moment und die haben wir
einmal in eines der triebwerke mit einer
etwas geringeren schubkraft als die 27
in den booster und in der ersten stufe
auch perfekt gezündet es ist wirklich
unglaublich
leute ihr das ist ein moment wo man
wirklich gänsehaut haben muss es ist
absolut irre
und ja wahnsinn wir haben 4000 zuschauer
fragen thomas was ist so die hauptfrage
im moment die hauptquartier ist ob ich
denn so können nein du bist nicht mal so
das ist ja schon viele leute nachgesagt
worden
auch thomas ist nicht mein sohn ja wir
haben hier wirklich eine einen
wirklichen geschichts moment erlebt und
ja und das ist da hören wir ihnen den
song achtung er ist space oddity das ist
es was klein dann hört man das auch so
also im original zubehör man jetzt hört
es euch an auf spotify oder sonstwo und
da sehen was tontechnik auf den displays
ist wirklich unglaublich selbst da hat
er eine kamera eingebaut wir können es
also sehen
es ist absolut irre riesenapplaus dort
vor ort unglaublich es ist wirklich
menschheitsgeschichte die maske
geschrieben hat und ja man sieht den
jubel dort und es ist wirklich absolut
irre so wir haben jetzt noch einige
minuten bis die booster landen werden
sie werden ja wie gesagt auf festland
landen dagegen das erste triebwerk wird
auf einer landeplattform landen einer mo
einer schwimmenden drohen die drohnen
plattform und ja dann wäre es das erste
mal dass wirklich drei dieser elemente
wieder auf der erde gleich zeit fast
gleichzeitig landen auch ganz wichtiger
punkt zwei von diesen elementen sind
schon mal mit einer falcon 9 gestartet
worden also das ist auch schon recycling
im besten sinne
und das ist ganz entscheidend auch bei
dieser mission das wieder bewiesen
worden ist das space ex wieder bewiesen
hat dass das funktioniert mit der
wiederverwendung weil das senkt die
kosten unglaublich denn statt einer
saturn 5 ich müsste ja nochmal nachdruck
und ich hauptsächlich hat glaube ich
damals ungefähr zehn milliarden gekostet
und hier sind die kosten in ganz anderen
rahmen das geht dann in richtung 90
millionen und auch der start eines space
shuttles der lag bei einer milliarde
dann im schnitt genau weiß man sich weil
es nie veröffentlicht wird und da viele
kosten dazukommen aber fakt ist die
kosten werden dadurch dramatisch
geringer und das ist dann auch der punkt
um dann zu sagen um dann auch allen masc
das ist ein argument zu sagen mit diesen
geringen kosten das schaffe ich es
raumschiffe zum mars zu senden sollen
jetzt muss ich mir gerade mal die
notizen zur massa geht da rausholen war
das ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
weil diese ferien heavy ist der letzten
zwischenstopp bevor die eben von der ich
gesprochen hat bfh entwickelt wird die
big fucking rocket oder die big felken
lockert die soll schon 2002 und 2010
also ich war jedenfalls tierisch bald
schon eingesetzt werden
die verfügt über deutlich stärkere
triebwerke es werden 31 rektor
triebwerke seien und jetzt geht man hier
noch mal eins vollbild weil hier sehen
wir jetzt eigentlich nicht dass
irgendwas es wird gesteuert doch der
kurs wird korrigiert dass auch mal ein
ganz wichtiger punkt wir wissen nicht
wohin der tesla fliegen wird mehreren
stunden nach dem start wird das
triebwerk was wir jetzt auch noch mal
sehen nochmals gezündet werden und ja
dann ja dann werden wir erfahren
irgendwann wohin die reise geht aber
erst in einigen stunden wenn wirklich
der kurs korrigiert wird
so und jetzt sind wir kurz vom booster
land da kommen oben rechts vor dem bus
landing sehen wir die booster
sie nähern sich dem boden gesehen dass
sie aus verschiedenen perspektiven sieht
ein bisschen aus wie eine abgebrannte
silvesterrakete ist vielleicht auch so
und ja aber alles hier sehen wir unten
die plattformen und zwar aus zwei
kameraperspektiven achtung jetzt stünden
die triebwerke wir sehen auch hier aber
kurz die andere stufe gesehen die
landeklappen haus eine wahnsinns
perspektive und in wenigen sekunden
unterschied landen beide booster perfekt
und zielgerichtet
das ist eine absolute revolution so was
dass das so perfekt klappt da haben
viele nicht mitgerechnet und ihnen was
für für ziemlich blöde erklärt dass er
überhaupt glaubt dass so etwas
funktionieren könnte warum sind wir auf
leihen dann gehen wir online jetzt sind
wir wieder da
okay wir sind wieder da so das war diese
aber hier die kollegen von spacex
geschrieben worden wir haben sie hier
live miterlebt und ich habe versprochen
dass ich noch ein paar daten zur big
fucking rocket big fucking rocken
bringen werde
die wird nämlich stärker als sie bisher
stärkste rakete sein die es gab sie wird
stärker als seine saturn 5 das ist die
rakete die die menschen zum mond
gebracht hat sein
sie wird während nämlich die saturn
135.000 tonnen 530 tonnen in die den
lohas opel bringen konnte wird die big
fucking rocket das mit bis zu 250 tonnen
machen also können fast zweimal so stark
wir gucken wir noch mal rein wissen der
zweiten stufe die jetzt nicht mehr
zündet sondern sie hat ihre ihre
flugrichtung jetzt erstmal richtung
sonne erreicht wie gesagt in einigen
stunden wird sie noch mal die bahn
korrigieren denn das ist der sinn
das raumschiff soll in die umlaufbahn um
die sonne gebracht werden und dann
richtung
fliegen aber wo genau wie genau wir
wissen es nicht wir werden das sicher
noch erfahren ja da sind die kollegen
von spacex die sich jetzt verabschieden
und wir bleiben auch noch ein bisschen
dran weil ich ein bisschen erzählen will
was eben diese bfa so besonders macht so
dass fünf mach' ich mir mal das den ton
von den kollegen auswahl der waren wir
die ganze zeit bei mir im ohr also wenn
ich mal nicht so ganz
hier in der kamera war dann lag es daran
dass ich hier mit dem ohr bei den
kollegen in den usa 31 liter triebwerke
das hatte ich erwähnen dass wird die bfa
antreiben die deutlich stärker sind als
die jetzt verwendeten berlin einst die
triebwerke ja und sie hat dann eine
zweite stufe die sieben rektor
triebwerke hat und der plan ist dann mit
dieser rakete erst mal in einen erd
orbit zu fahren zu fliegen und dort dann
sie nochmals zu betanken so dass sie
ohne die schwerkraft der erde über
richtung zu müssen dann richtung mars
fliegen kann sie es wird ein größeres
volumen haben sie wird ein größeres
volumen haben ein eher als ein airbus a
380 mit 825 kubikmetern 100 100
passagiere sollen reingehen 40 kabinen
soll sie haben ja und auch da ist die
wiederverwertung das ist wirklich
entscheidendes darf man bei dem was wir
jetzt hier alles gesehen haben nicht
vergessen das war die eigentliche
sensation dass hier die drei elemente
der ersten stufe die beiden booster und
die hauptstufe auf der erde wieder
landen konnten und jetzt demnächst in
der feld hinein oder in der nächsten
velten heavy wiederverwertet werden
können
der plan ist sogar die stufen beim
nächsten mal genau dort landen zu lassen
wo sie wieder starten so dass da auch
wieder keine kosten entstehen um
bauteile fluggeräte stufen und so weiter
triebwerke von a nach b zu
transportieren
dann könnte man direkt wieder weiter
starten das heißt betanken reparieren
und so weiter und so fort ja und die
erste stufe bei der big fell können
rocket sage ich jetzt mal die wird
tausendmal soll 1000 mal wieder
verwertbar sein
dann soll es ein element für oben gehen
was wir genau jetzt als payload gesehen
haben
das wird bei der big völkern rocket kann
das ein tanker sein also in dem
treibstoff in den erdorbit gebracht wird
der dann 100 mal verwendet werden kann
und die oberstufe also das raumschiff
soll dann zwölf mal verwendet werden
können der erstflug ist genau 2022
unbemannt mit zwei bosse zum mars
geplant das ist wirklich der absolute
wahnsinn oder auch noch eine kleine
neben das finde ich wirklich lustig man
kommt ja heute dabei sein bei dem start
auf dem cape kennedy und dafür gab es
tickets und zwar in vier kategorien das
war die ticket klosters
fahrzeugkategorie closer das war die
kategorie close ist also was ist quasi
immer näher ran gerückt aber das sind
kilometer die tribünen waren
kilometerweit entfernt und viel witz da
war man dann so nah dass man wirklich
die hitze auf dem gesicht gespürt hat
das sind aber auch immer noch einige
kilometer entfernt von der startrampe
weil sonst wäre es ja zu gefährlich
gewesen 1420 tonnen sind da jetzt ins
weltall geschossen worden 70 meter hoch
war die rakete ja und ihnen maske meinte
das ist waren wahrscheinlich waren das
noch waren das noch reste von den vom 8
ein paar rußpartikel er sagt es gibt
eine 50 50 chance aber wie ich mir so in
letzter zeit das angesehen habe ich habe
dass das im letzten jahr wirklich
verfolgt wie viele landungen der stufen
vom feld hinein schief gegangen sind man
darf nicht vergessen die dinge sind ja
wirklich riesig die sehen da so klein
und fein oder sind riesige türme
das hat ja ein paar mal nicht geklappt
aber dann eben doch und es wurde immer
besser
ja es ist wirklich absolut wahnsinn was
wir hier gesehen haben
sie haben übrigens die startrampe die
musste ihnen maske versichern gegen eine
katastrophe gegen den wirklichen crash
der ja durchaus hätte passieren können
für 110 millionen dollar so dass die
startrampe hätte danach wieder aufbauen
können er hat sie
von der nasa geliefert geleast für die
nächsten 20 jahre
also das ist jetzt die space ex straße
rampe also tatsächlich die historische
apollo startrampe ist für die nächsten
jahre
die space ex startrampe und ich würde
sagen habt ihr noch fragen gibt es das
was ich beantworten kann was und
ansonsten mit dem konto
das fragen gelöchert welcher chor der
gerade weiterfliegt geht es nach so ihr
meint gemeint die die dass das
raumschiff genau das weiß man noch nicht
also der punkt ist ja es geht zum mars
als wissen wir alle aber was vielen mast
mit dem raumschiff ohr hat das haben wir
bisher noch nicht erfahren wie gesagt in
einige stunden wird das mal merlin 1d
triebwerk im raumschiff oder am payload
es ist ja letztlich nur eine lade lade
login dass das der der tesla auf
eingebracht worden ist wohin das lade
dort fliegen wird was er damit vorhat
es ist wirklich es ist wieder hin macht
das ist einfach phänomenal was für ein
sinn für mode und wie er uns da auf die
folter spannt wir werden erst morgen
wahrscheinlich wissen wohin der tesla
roadster wirklich fliegt er übrigens
auch noch mal ganz wichtiges detail er
wurde noch einmal speziell umgerüstet so
dass er auch das vakuum aushält
vielleicht hat er damit noch einen
besonderen plan und wir kriegen in
einigen stunden vielleicht oder in
einigen tagen bilder geliefert mit denen
wir so nicht gerechnet haben ja ich
würde immer sagen das war's mit dem
livestream zu einem der sensationellsten
wirklich sensationellsten ereignisse
ich weiß viele beschweren sich darüber
dass ich dieses und andere superlative
er ständig wieder verwendet aber das hat
auch mit unserer mit unserem zeitalter
zu tun
es ist wirklich unglaublich was da jetzt
passiert ist und ja wir werden noch die
folgen zu spüren bekommen und vielleicht
wird der ein oder andere ich kann euch
sagen ich bleibe jetzt erstmal lieber
auf der erde
aber vielleicht wird der ein oder andere
von euch dann mal in einigen jahren zum
mars fliegen und von dort berichten also
sagt bescheid wenn er damals diesen live
stream gesehen habt wenn ihr auf dem
mars seite und meldet euch bei mir da
bin ich dann doch sehr gespannt wie's da
auf dem mars ist und was sich da in
zukunft ergibt denn das sind ist der
plan eben auch nicht nur den mars
sondern er hat auch die die daten
veröffentlicht welche fracht er zum
pluto bringen kann und so weiter und so
fort also ihnen macht sieht das ganze
als den start der des sonnensystems der
besiedlung des sonnensystems durch den
menschen an
und wir wissen sie auch von stephen
hawking der hat ja auch gesagt wir
müssen die erde in den nächsten 100
jahren verlassen ich bin nicht ganz so
davon überzeugt weil die erste ist immer
noch der lebens freundlichste ort das
ist schon ein gewisser aufwand den mars
zu tera formen und ja von daher denke
ich es ist auch keine so schlechte idee
die welt so zu gestalten dass wir es
auch auf ihr weiter aushalten können und
nicht dass es hier irgendwann mal so
heiß wird das vielleicht der mars der
angenehmere ort ist ja dann würde ich
mal sagen gibt es noch fragen genau es
gibt ja noch mal die frage kommen der
dritte booster auf dem wasser landen
sollte es gibt ja zwei plattform auf dem
wasser von spacex aber sehr da werden
hat die kapazitäten auch immer weiter
ausgebaut so dass auf dem land gelandet
werden kann
auf diesen schiffen die ja auch zunächst
erstmal gebaut worden sind weil es viel
sicherer war die raumschiffe dort landen
zu lassen als wenn sie dem staat
umgekippt wäre was ja auch ein paar mal
passiert ist das hatte keine folgen und
auf dem land hätte ein großer schaden
entstehen können deswegen hat spacex
zunächst diese schiffe gebaut aber jetzt
geht es eben auch an land ja ein
absoluter wahnsinn und ich würde mal
sagen vielen dank dass er dabei gewesen
seit wir lachen wir jetzt übertragen
das kann ich nicht sagen kann er uns ja
ich kann sogar sagen ein blick auf die
uhr ein blick auf die uhr und gerne eine
gute halbe stunde haben übertragen
und ja jetzt ist das display lot also
die ladung
der ersten gestarteten felton harry auf
dem weg zum mars wo genau wie genau und
was genau das passiert darüber werden
wir damit demnächst hier auf klicks um
berichten dann sagen wir mal
nachzuschauen vielen dank fürs zuschauen
tschüss und bis zum nächsten mal morgen
gibt es wieder ein klicks um
science-fiction videos